eigentlich mit grünheide genauso wenig
grün wesentlich wichtiger an die
kundschaft anders genau also was mich
immens stört ist der ständige zuwachs in
den letzten jahren der verschmelzung von
konzernen und politik und zwar in einer
sichtbaren weise dass man manchmal
wirklich denkt ja wo sind da noch die
volks interessen die des einzelnen
bürgers weil man sich da so
zusammensetzt und dann miteinander deals
macht und dann gibt zwar noch ein
interesse gibt es noch die world
economic forum wo sie dann noch
zusammensitzen und noch nicht
großkonzerne noch ein paar dies machen
und so weiter auch in
verschwörungstheorien
das ist keine verschwörung auf keinen
fall jeden fall ist ich bin in der
bürgerinitiative von grünheide habe
hautnah miterlebt wie das dann so
abläuft in der praxis im zusammenhang
mit umweltschutz und nimmt zusammen mit
bürgerschutz auch also bürgerrechte bei
einem öffentlich laufenden verfahren in
zusammenhang mit mit diesem grünheider
projekt also mit dieser firma und ich
habe dort dinge erlebt hier konnte ich
gar nicht fassen weil das ist nicht sehr
trockene gegen das ist brandenburg und
berlin haben einfach große
wasserprobleme schon viele viele jahre
liegt sicher auch an sandboden liegt
auch an der art und weise der wald
strukturen dass viele nadelbäume sind
aber dann muss man natürlich dagegen
steuern und es gab sehr viele konzept in
den letzten 20 jahren plötzlich flogen
die alle einfach weg es wurde alles in
den mülleimer gekippt und es hieß der
mann also in dem fall elias bekommt ein
gebiet ein waldstück das direkt im
natura-2000-gebiet direkt nebendran
liegt das höchst geschütztes naturgebiet
und unten drunter gibt es ein
trinkwasserschutz körper und dieser
trinkwasserschutz körper und jetzt kommt
es dann
versorgt ich glaube 120.000 menschen der
gesamten region und ist sozusagen
zentrum einer einer jahr trinkwasser
ebene unterirdisch die ihnen das
berliner urstromtal rhein fließt in die
spree und unter anderem auch berlin
versorgt und jetzt nimmt diese firma ich
glaube ein drittel der wasser einnahmen
sich die ein bürger entscheidet dafür
gestimmt dass die produktionsstätten ein
bürgerentscheid gab es nicht es gab
keinen fall also keinen bürgerentscheid
es gab stadtrats diskussion gab einen
bürgermeister der ist extrem
vorangetrieben hat und es gab einen
umweltminister und einen
wirtschaftsminister dort vor ort und
einen ministerpräsident der so das hat
mich selbst gelesen anweisungen ans
umweltministerium gegeben hat so viele
so viele dinge zu tun wie nur möglich um
vorab genehmigungen zu erteilen nachdem
emissionsschutz gesetz die haben bis
heute keine tatsächliche baugenehmigung
nur immissionsschutzgesetz kriegen so
schnell alles vorbei
sein china
insofern zu will ihre these aufgreifen
von verschmelzen interessen zwischen
kontakten werthaltig in brandenburg gibt
es leider keine konzern deshalb
verschmelzen die hier dieser ganz
besonders mit der unendlichen weil es ja
nur erklären weil hier geht es um 40.000
arbeitsplätze in einer dürftigen 10.000
haben zugesagt und es sind im moment
dreieinhalb tage gut aber es ist soll
mal 40 werden
also jedenfalls viele arbeitsplätze da
hängen ja noch menschen dran die das
besonders attraktiv machen diese frage
na ja sieht der bürgerinitiative
angehören mit welchen argumenten haben
dann die zuständigen behörden den
hinweis auf den verlust von grundwasser
abgewehrt die haben das aber hat nicht
abgewehrt also soweit ich saß zwei
wochen in dieser in dieser anhörung und
habe unter anderem die bürger vertreten
und wir haben darauf hingewiesen es wird
eine naturkatastrophe auf uns zurollen
die jetzt schon da ist weil jetzt schon
das wasserwerk da trügen die neuzuzüger
und da kommen einige mit 102 liter pro
tag
rationiert jeder haushalt kriegt nur
noch 102 liter 165 liter sind der
normale durchschnitt für jeden haushalt
also da darf praktisch derjenige der
jetzt hinzuzieht nicht mal mehr seinen
rasen dürfen wir da drei kinder hat und
warten will kriegt der strafe weil es zu
viele das wirklich stellt euch das mal
vor ich meine das ist ja im moment die
rationalisierte rationieren weil nicht
genug wasser da ist und diese firma ist
in der ersten ausbaustufe und hat jetzt
schon 1,3 millionen
kubikmeter und will noch zwei
ausbaustufen machen und will sich auch
nochmal 100 hektar wald holen obwohl 265
sind sowie ausgerechnet wurde also die
wollen sich da aus brighton tatsache ist
dieses gebiet ist der falsche ort und
wir haben das in der anhörung immer
wieder gesagt es gibt andere orte in
hamburg auf jeden fall spielsweise
lausitz zb da gibt es industriebrachen
noch nie fordern und es auf den punkt
das dass ich weder
untersuchungsausschuss und sie waren das
ausgeschlossen wird dass das land würde
das wenn man mich jetzt so fragt würde
ich sagen also arbeitsplätze ja auf
jeden fall aber sie war ein ziehen
lassen wird in grünheide ich halte es
für den absolut falschen ort und ich
weiß dass es so oder so zur katastrophe
kommt wenn dir das ignorieren und ich
finde es erschreckend was wir dort
erlebt haben dass also das dass das
umweltamt kriegt offensichtlich so wie
ich gelesen habe anweisungen vom
ministerium und da wird ignoriert und
wenn sie dann von wasserknappheit reden
sagen sie die bösen bauern dürften nicht
so viel wasser rein aber tatsache ist
dass die leute jetzt schon probleme mit
wasser und es wird irgendwann auch
berlin treffen weil nämlich von dort
auch die wasserversorgung nach berlin
geht das ist ein riesenproblem sei es ja
da halten sie ist auch für den falschen
ort das kann ich überhaupt nicht
beurteilen um es mal ganz kurz zu sagen
aber eines kann ich auch sagen
wenn das ganze in china gebaut wird
können wir gar nichts kontrollieren uns
mal kurz zu sagen wir wollen dass eine
so genannte verkehrswende stattfindet
dass wir uns anders bewegen klar schön
wenn jeder irgendwie nv nutzt also
öffentliche personennahverkehr den gibt
es nicht so sehr im ländlichen raum wir
wollen arbeitsplätze haben das heißt
sehr sehr häufig der osten wird
abgehängt wir haben keine arbeitsplätze
und dann sage ich schon sehr klar ja
wenn wir wir haben ja von tesla
gesprochen wenn wir jetzt die mobilität
voranbringen wollen dann muss es auch
irgendwo gebaut werden das ist so
ähnlich wie mit den windrädern und mit
vielem anderen auch man ist dafür das
ist irgend eine wende gibt aber bitte
nicht vor meiner haustür und ich kann
das jetzt nicht ich kann weder
verifizieren noch falsifizieren aber
eine behörde kann nicht einfach dinge
türken ums ehrlich sozusagen eine
behörde kann nicht auch eine
umweltbehörde kann nicht einfach gesetze
und regeln ignorieren also ich kann
jetzt noch mal sagen als bürger muss ich
davon ausgehen dass das stimmt so lange
bis das gegenteil bewiesen ist und wenn
es ein untersuchungsausschuss gäbe kann
man ja machen nachdem das spiel
da galt werden aber ich glaube wir
sonntag gibt es jemanden der partei die
sind halt ich nicht beurteilen aber ich
hoffe dass es irgendwann mal einrichten
weil ich saß zwei wochen in diesem in
dieser anhörung und ich weiß genau was
da läuft und ich kann in den eins sagen
da wurde jedes rechtliches schlupfloch
genutzt um vor vorab jegliche art von
zulassung zuzulassen bestimmte sachen
sind bis heute nicht überprüft da sind
auch gelder die eigentlich für die
aufarbeitung von der ferne blase die
muster weg was im
trinkwasserschutzgebiet da ist eine drin
die ist hochgefährlich wenn die platz
ist das ganze trinkwasserschutzgebiet
vergiftet zwei millionen euro pro jahr
vom bund wurden ganz land bezahlt die
sind irgendwo hin geschlossen das ist
nicht reparieren muss man am lauten hier
kann eine nirgendwohin geflossen sind
also dann können sie mehrfachen
untersucht das ist dann auch was für die
bild -zeitung sicherlich da jemanden
hinzuschicken zu recherchieren
also wenn gelder veruntreut werden vom
bund nicht so verwandt worden dann haben
wir ein ganz anderes thema und das ist
ja kein wir haben einen so kalt sehen
was meint ihr nach mein thema ist nicht
nur dass drei augen fünf uhren
geschlossen wurden und fünf männer ich
hatte wirklich den eindruck ich sitz vor
drei affen die so machen
ich störe mich daran dass man
unterschiedlich mit menschen umgeht also
eine mittelständische firma hätte diese
möglichkeiten es ist schwer es dann und
eine behauptung als wenn sie nicht wären
also ja wirklich meisten leuten die dort
wohnen ja wie das nicht verifizieren das
ist eine behauptung frauen neigen sie
haben ja sicher wir haben ja vorher
china erwähnt ich will jetzt nicht eine
gegenthese haben aber ich finde es gut
wenn wir weniger bürokratisch arbeiten
ich finde es gut wenn sachen schnell
passieren in diesem land wir brauchen
arbeitsplätze
es geht um den wohlstand es geht um das
führende position in der welt und es
kann nicht sein dass es nicht gegen wie
wirklich ich kenne mich da nicht aus
aber ich kann nicht sein dass wir
prioritäten zu setzen dass wohlstand der
allerletzte denn wir betrachten und
warten erstmal auf aber hätte man wasser
aber wir hätten schon recht wir hätten
schon gerne china mit umweltschutz
absoluten der ohne umwelt so
gerne irgendwann sagen war der stellen
das auch überhaupt nicht beurteilen was
frau nagel sagt aber
natürlich können wir uns vorstellen dass
die behörden die augen zugemacht haben
weil der ministerpräsident gesagt hat
das wollen wir ich halte das für unser
land wahnsinnig wichtig lasst mal fünfe
grade sein
das wird schon irgendwo hinhauen